okay so I'm delighted to introduce our
first lot of invited speakers and so
we're gonna have two invited speakers
today so starting off we're going to
have a sheaf my swanee who's going to be
talking about self attention for
generative models and in particular
we'll introduce some of the work on
transformers that he is well known for
along with his colleagues and then as a
sort of a special edition we're also
going to have enough Wong talking about
some applications of this work
they're actually at least a couple of
people in the class who are actually
interest in music applications so this
will be your one chance of the course to
see music applications of deep learning
okay so I'll hand it over Turkey thanks
Kristin there thanks Evie and I was
actually here to make the class less
dull so she's the highlight not this guy
so uh so hi everyone
excited to be here this is a very large
class first invited speaker no pressure
so hopefully this will all go well so
yes so the talk is going to be about
self attention and so the purpose is is
not going to be just to talk about a
particular model but as as in Paris
isten and like well I'm an empiricist
and I consume machine learning to apply
it to various tasks and and and a
starting point always as fast as
question you know what are the what's
the structure in my dataset or the
symmetries in my dataset and is there a
model that exists that that's a very
good that has the inductive bias used to
model these properties that exist in my
data set so hopefully over the course of
this this lecture and I will convince
you that self attention indeed does have
some has the ability models of inductive
biases that potentially could be useful
for the problems that you care about so
this talk is going to be our learning
representations primarily of variable
length data well we have images but most
of it is going to be variable and theta
and and and and all of us care about
this problem because well in deep
learning and deep learning is all about
representation learning
and if and building the right tools for
learning representations is an important
factor in achieving empirical success
now the models of choice the primary
workhorse for perhaps even now and/or up
to this point have been recurrent neural
networks how many people here are
familiar with RNAs so definitely up to
this point the primary workers have been
recurrent neural networks and some of
the more some some gated variants that
explicitly add multiplicative
interactions like Ellis tiems they also
they also have mechanisms that allow for
better gradient transfer and some recent
variants like gated recurrent units that
are simplification they're kind of the
they're they dominate this this
recurrent landscape and typically how
two recurrent neural networks learn or
produce representations they consume a
string or a sentence even an image to
imagine you know in a particular in
sequentially and at each at each
position at each time step the producer
they produce a a continuous
representation that's a summarization of
everything that they've actually
crunched through now so in their in the
realm of large data having parallel
models is quite is quite beneficial in
fact I was actually reading Oliver
Selfridge he was he was a professor at
MIT and he had this sir he wrote the
precursor to deepen its it's called
pandemonium's i would recommend
everybody to read it and he has this
fascinating note that you know if you
give me more parallel computation i'll
just add more data and make it slower so
you can consume more data and and
recurrence recurrence sort of just by
construction limits parallelization
because you have to you have to wait
until you're waiting for a particular
time point to produce their
representation whether if there's any
questions please raise your hands I'll
hopefully look around and and be able to
attend to your question and again and
and now because we're actually producing
these representations we're sort of
summarizing you know if you want to pass
informational if you want to pass court
reference information
we kind of have to shove all of this
inside his fixed size vector so it could
potentially be difficult to model and
while they've been successful in
language explicit they don't have the
architecture doesn't have a very clear
explicit way to model hierarchy which is
which is something that's very important
in language now so they have been Devon
there's been excellent work precursor to
self attention that actually surmounted
some of these difficulties so what were
these difficulties basically there's a
convolutional sequence models where you
have these limited receptive field
convolutions that that again consume the
sentence now nod not sequentially but in
depth and they produce representations
for every they produce representations
of your variable length sequences and
they're trivial to paralyze because you
can apply this convolution
simultaneously at every position each
layers trivial to paralyze the the
serial dependencies are only in the
number of layers you can get you can you
can get these local dependencies
efficiently because at a single
application of a convolution can consume
all the information inside its local
receptive field now if you want to have
these really long distance interactions
while you don't have to pass through a
linear number of steps you still because
these because these receptive fields are
local you might you might need something
like linear and depth or logarithmic if
you're doing something like dilated
convolutions so they still need the
number of layers that are needed are
still a function of the length of the of
the off your string but they're a great
development and they actually push a lot
of research like wave r and n for
example as a classic sort of success
story of convolutional convolutional
sequence models even bite nits
now so far attention has been like one
of the most important competence the
sort of content base you know memory
retrieval mechanism and it's
content-based because you have your
decoder that attends to all this content
that's your encoder and then just sort
of decides what to what because what
information to absorb based on how
similar this content is to every
position in the memory so this has been
a very critical mechanism in in neural
machine translation so now the question
that we asked was like why not just use
attention for representations and now
peer support sort of a rough framework
of this
this representation mechanism would look
like the way of just sort of repeating
what attention is essentially now I
imagine you have you want to represent
the word read represent the word
represent you want to construct its new
representation and then first you you
attend or you you compare yourself you
compare your content and at the
beginning it could just be a word
embedding you compare a content with all
your words with all with all the
embeddings and based on these based on
these compatibilities or these
comparisons you produce a you produce a
weighted combination off your entire
neighborhood and based on that weighted
combination you you summarize all that
information so it's like your reexpress
in yourself insert in terms of a
weighted combination of your entire
neighborhood
that's what attention does and you can
add feed-forward layers to basically
sort of compute new features for you now
so the first part is going to be about
how like some of the properties of self
attention actually helped us in text
generation like what inductive biases
are actually useful and be empirically
showed that indeed they they move the
needle in text generation and this is
going to be able to machine translation
but their other work also that we'll
talk about later so now with this with
this sort of with this attention
mechanism you get this we get a constant
path length so all pairs all a word can
a position can interact with any
position every position simultaneously
hopefully if the number of positions is
not too many attention just by virtue of
like it's a construction you have a soft
max you get these gating and
multiplicative interactions and again
I'm not going to be able to explain why
but it's it's interesting like you've
seen these models like even even the
even pixel pixel CNN or when it was
actually modeling images they explicitly
had to add these multiplicative
interactions inside the model to to
basically beat iron ins and attention
just by construction gets this because
you're you're multiplying the attention
probabilities with your with your
activations it's trivial to parallelize
why because you can just do attention
with Matt malls especially the variant
that we use in our paper in our work and
so now the question is convolutional
sequences convolutional sequence models
have been very successful in in in in in
generative tasks for text can we
actually do the same or achieve the same
but with attention as our primary
or course for representation learning so
just to sort of add some context and
there's been some there's been some up
to up to the transformer they've been a
lot of great work on using self
attention primarily for classification
within they were stuff there was a work
on self attention within the confines of
like recurrent neural networks perhaps
the closest to us is memory networks by
Western Civ butter where they actually
had a version of recurrent attention but
they didn't have but they didn't
actually empirically they didn't show it
to work on sort of conditional modeling
like the translation and their mechanism
was like yeah they were using sort of a
fixed they were using a fixed query at
every step so there was it leaves
something to be desired that this still
have this question is it actually going
to work on large-scale machine
translation systems or large-scale text
generation systems so this is sort of
the the culmination of the the the self
attention our self attention work this
is the Trent though and we put it
together in the transformer model and so
how does this look like so we're going
to use a tension you're going to use
attention primarily for computing
representations so if your input imagine
you're doing English a German
translation so you have your words and
notice that attention is permutation
invariant so you just change the order
of your positions you change the order
of your words and and it's not going to
affect the actual output so in our in
order to maintain order we add we add
position representations and there's two
kinds that we tried on the paper these
these fantastic sinusoids with no I'm
sure she invented and we also use
learned representations which are very
plain vanila both of them work equally
well and so so first we have so the
encoder looks as follows right so we
have a self attention layer that just
recomputes the representation for every
position simultaneously using attention
then we have a feed-forward layer and we
also have residual residual connections
and I'll sort of give you a glimpse of
what these residual connections might be
bringing that is between every every
layer and the input we have a skip
connection that just adds the
activations and then this tuple of self
attention and feed-forward layer just
essentially repeats now on the decoder
side we
we have a sort of standard
encoder/decoder architecture on the
decoder side we mimic a language model
using self attention and the way to
mimic a language model using self
attention is to impose causality by just
masking out the positions that you can
look at so basically the the first
position it's it can't look forward to
legal to look forward it can look at
itself because we actually shift the
input so it's not copying it's kind of
surprising with these models is very
easy to copy at one point when early on
it was even hard to you know do copying
with record models but now at least we
can copy really well which is a positive
sign I think overall but so now on the
decoder side we have we have this causal
self attention layer followed by encoder
decoder attention where we actually
attend to the last layer of the encoder
and a feed-forward layer and this trip
will repeat some a few times and at the
end we have the standard cross entropy
loss and so sort of staring at the at
the particular variant of the self of
the attention mechanism mechanism that
we use we went for both we went for
simplicity and speed so so how do you
actually compute attention so imagine
you want to re represent the position
eetu and we are going to first linearly
linearly transform it into a query and
then we're going to linearly transform
every position in your neighborhood or
let's say every position at the input
because this is the of the encoder side
to a key and these linear
transformations can actually be thought
as features and I'll talk more about it
later on so it's like it's it's
basically a bilinear form you're
projecting these vectors into a space
where a dot product is a good where just
a dot product is a good proxy for
similarity okay so now you have your
load should see just do a softmax
computer convex combination and now
based on this convex combination you're
going to then re-express e to or in
terms of this convex combination of all
the vectors of all these positions and
before doing before doing the convex
combination be again do a linear
transformation to produce values and
then we do a second linear
transformation just to mix this
information and pass it through a pass
it through a feed-forward layer and this
is and all of this can be expressed
basically in two in two in two mate
multiplications and the square root
factors just to make sure that these
these dot products don't blow up it's
just a scaling factor and and and why is
this particular why is this mechanism
attractive well it's just really fast
you can do this very quickly on a GPU
and Sam you can do it simultaneously for
all positions with just two matte moles
and a soft max on the decoder side it's
it's exactly the same except we impose
causality by just adding ten e minus ten
nine to the logit so it base it's just
you just get zero probabilities on those
positions so we just impose causality by
by adding these highly negative values
on the attention on the attention
Roget's is everything so that was a
question so okay so attention is really
attention is cheap
so because it's because this variant of
attention just involved two involves two
matrix multiplications it's quadratic in
the length of your sequence and now
what's the computational profile of our
ends or convolutions they're quadratic
in the dimension because basically you
can just think of a convolution just
flattening your input in just applying a
linear transformation on top of it right
so and when does this actually become
very attractive this becomes very very
attractive when your dimension is a much
larger than your length which is the
case for machine translation now we will
talk about cases when there's when this
is not true then we have to we have to
do we have to make other model
developments but but for short sequences
or sequences with your length does where
a dimension dominates length attentions
are very has a very favorable
computation profiler as you can see it's
about four times faster than and RNN and
and faster than a convolutional model
where that you have a kernel of like
filter with three so so there's still
one problem no here's something so in
language typically we want to know who
like who did what to whom right so now I
imagine you applied a convolutional
filter because you actually have
different linear transformations based
on relative distances like these this
this this linear transformation on the
word who on the concept we can have the
this concept of who and and and pick out
different information from this
embedding of the word I and this linear
transformation that the red linear
transformation can pick out different
information from kicked and the blue
linear transformation can pick out
different different information from
ball now when you have a single
attention layer this is difficult
because all because of just a convex
combination or you have the same linear
transformation everywhere all that's
available to is just is just mixing
proportions so you can't pick out
different pieces of information from
different places well what if we had one
attention layer for who so you can think
of it intentionally as something like a
feature detector almost like because a
particular it might try to it might
because it carries with it a linear
transformation so it's projecting them
in a space that which starts carrying
maybe about syntax or it's projecting in
a space which starts carrying about who
or what then we can have another
attention layer for our attention head
for what did--what and another attention
head for for for whom to whom and all of
this can actually be done in parallel
and that's actually and that's exactly
what we do and for efficiency instead of
actually having these dimensions operate
in in a large space we just we just
reduce the dimensionality of all these
heads and we operate these attention
layers in parallel sort of bridging the
gap now here's a perhaps well here's a
little quiz I mean can you actually is
there a combination of heads or is there
a configuration in which you can
actually exactly simulate a convolution
probably with more parameters I think
there should be a simple way to show
that if you had more heads or heads were
a function of positions you could
probably just simulate a convolution but
although with a lot of parameters so it
can in in in in the limit it can
actually simulate a convolution and also
you can all we can continue to enjoy the
benefits of parallelism but we did
increase the number of soft maxes
because each head then carries with it a
soft max but the amount of flops didn't
change because we instead of actually
having these heads operated in very
large dimensions they are operating in
very small dimensions so when we applied
this on on machine translation we were
able to dramatically outperform previous
results on English German and English
French translation so we had a pretty
standard set up thirty-two thousand word
vocabularies word piece and coatings WMT
for WMT 2014 was our test set 2013 to
the dev set and and some of these
results were much stronger than even of
previous ensemble models and an English
French also we had some we had some very
favorable favorable results and VNV
state-of-the-art now stepping back a bit
I'm not claiming that we we arrived at
an architecture that has better
expressivity than an LST I mean there's
there's there's there's theorems that
say that all those teams can model any
function perhaps all we did was just
build an architecture that was good for
SGD because stochastic gradient descent
could just train this architecture
really well because the gradient
dynamics and attention are very simple
attention is just a linear combination
and I think that's I think that's
actually favorable but hopefully as we
as we go on but well I'd also like to
point out that you know we do explicit
we do explicitly model all all paths
connection or all pairwise connections
and it has added Vantage of very clear
modeling very clear relationships
directly between between any two words
and like hopefully we'll be able to hell
show that there are other inductive
biases that it's not just like building
architectures that that are good for
that are good inductive biases for SGD
so frameworks a lot of our work was
initially pushed out in tensor the
tensor maybe that might change in the
future with the arrival of Jax there's
an there's a framework also from Amazon
called Sakai there's also a fair seek
does the convolutional sequence of
sequins toolkit from Facebook that the
problem I'm actually not sure if it has
a transformer implementation but they
have some really good sequence to
sequence models as well okay so the
importance of residuals so we have these
residual residual connections between so
we have these residual connections that
go from here to here to here here to
here like between every pair of layers
and it's interesting so we so what we do
is we just add the position informations
at the input to the model and we don't
infuse we don't infuse or we don't
inject position information at every
layer so when we severed these residual
connections and we look stare that these
stare to these attention just to be
the center sort of the middle map is
this attention distribution you actually
basically it's been unable to pick this
diagonal it should have a very strong
diagonal focus and so what has happened
was these residuals were carrying this
position information to every layer and
because these subsequent layers had no
notion of position they were finding it
hard to actually attend this is the
encoder/decoder attention which
typically ends up being diagonal now so
then we said okay so then we actually
continued we continued to sever the
residuals but we added position
information back in at every layer we
injected position information back in
and we didn't recover the accuracy but
we did get some of this sort of diagonal
focus back in so the residuals are doing
more but they're certainly definitely
moving this position information to the
model there they're pumping this
position information through the model
okay so so that was that was so so now
we saw that you know being able to sort
model both long and short short term
relationships along long and short
distance relationships with with
attention is beneficial for for text
generation
what kind of inductor inductive biases
they actually appear or what kind of
phenomena appear in images and something
that we constantly constantly see in
images in music is this notion of
repeating structure that's very similar
to each other you have these motifs that
repeat in in different scales so for
example there's another artificial but
beautiful example of self similarity
where you have this van Gogh painting
where this texture or this these little
objects just repeat these images or
these different pieces of the image are
very so similar to each other but they
might have different scales again in
music here's a motif that repeats they
could have it could have like various
like spans of time between and in
between it so so so this so to be
attempted after this to see will chasis
question can self attention help us in
modeling other objects like images so
the the path we took was sort of
standard auto regressive image modeling
the probabilistic image modeling not
ganz because it was well one it was very
easy if you had a language model almost
so this is just like language modeling
on images and also training at maximum
likely it allows you to sort of measure
measure how well you're doing on on or
near held-out set and it also gives you
diversity so hopefully you're covering
all possible different kinds of images
you so and to this point there's all be
added
vonage that also been there been good
work on using recurrent models like
pixel art and pixel CNN that that we're
actually getting some very good
compression rates and again here
originally the argument was that well
you know in images because there because
you want symmetry because you want like
if you have a face you want you want one
year to sort of match with the other if
you had a large receptive field which
you could potentially get with the
tension at a lower computational cost
then it should benefit in it then it
should be quite beneficial for for
images for images and you wouldn't need
many layers like you do in convolutions
to actually get dependencies between
these far away pixels so it seemed like
self attention would have been a would
have what about what it was already a
good computational mechanism right but
this sort of but it was actually
interesting to see how it even modeled
naturally model self similarity and
people have used self similarity and
image generation like you know this is
this really cool work by F Rose where
they actually see okay
in the training said what are those
patches that are really that are really
similar to me and based on the patches
that are really similar to me I'm gonna
fill up the information so it's like
actually doing image generation there's
this really classic work called
non-local means where they do image
denoising where they want to denoise
this sort of this patch p and they say
i'm going to based on my similarity
between all other patches in my image
I'm going to compute some function of
content-based similarity and based on
the similarity I'm going to pull
information so and and exploiting this
fact that images are very so similar and
this has also been sort of applied in
some recent work now if you just took
this encoder self attention mechanism
and just replace these word embeddings
with patches and it's kind of exactly
what it's doing it's it's computing this
notion of content-based similarity
between these elements and then based on
this content-based similarity it
constructs a convex combination that
essentially brings these things together
so it's it's a very nice it was it was
quite it was very pleasant to see that
well this is a differentiable way of
doing the on local means and and we took
the transformer architecture and
replaced words with pixels there was
some there were some architecture
adjustments to do and so this was but
this was basically the kind of it was
very similar to the original work
and here the position representations
instead of being you know
one-dimensional they were because we're
not dealing with sequences we have
two-dimensional position representations
okay so I pointed out before attention
is a very very favorable computational
profile if your length if your dimension
dominates length with the chap which is
absolutely untrue for absolutely untrue
for images because even for like 32 but
even for 32 by 32 images when you
flatten them and you have you flatten
them you go 32 you get thirty seventy
two positions six your standard C for
image so a simple solution because like
convolutions have I mean you get Trent
convolutions have basically looked at
local windows and you get translational
equivariance
we said okay let's adopt the same
strategy and also there's a lot of
spatial locality and images but now we
will still have a better computational
profile if you're if you're receptive
field is still smaller than your
dimension you can afford you can
actually still do much more long
distance computation than a standard
convolution because your because your
quadratic in length so as long as we
didn't increase our length beyond the
dimension we still had a favorable
computational profile and so the way we
did it was we essentially had two kinds
of rasterization x' so we had a
one-dimensional rasterization we had a
sort of single query block which was
which was then attending or to the into
a larger memory block in this rasterized
fashion along the along along the rows
then we tried another form of
rasterization falling standard
two-dimensional locality where yet maybe
actually produced the image in in blocks
and within each block we had a
rasterization scheme again these this
image transformer layer was very similar
we had two-dimensional position
representations along with queries with
the same with a very similar attention
mechanism and we tried both
super-resolution and unconditional and
conditional image generation this was
this was Nia in the key prime R I and
the cup and a few other authors from
brain and we presented at ICML and we
were able to achieve better perplexity
than existing models so
so snail is actually another model that
used mixed vote convolutions and self
attention and there they are performed
us on on on bits per dimension so we
were measuring perplexity because these
are probabilistic models of
probabilistic models it's like basically
a language model of images and and it
just and your and the factorization of
your language model just depends on how
your rasterize in the in the in the 1d
rasterization women first rows and then
columns in the 2d rasterization we went
block wise and inside each block be
rasterized on image net we achieve
better perplexities and so yeah i mean
we're not again level right I mean this
feared this is I think probabilists auto
regressive image generation by this
point had not reached scans at iclear
2019 there's a paper by now that
actually uses self attention and gets
very very good quality images but what
we what we observed was we were getting
structural objects fairly well like can
people recognize what the second row is
I said most almost everyone said cars
I'm not going to ask who said something
else but he has their cars yeah and so
though and the last row is another
vehicles like so essentially when
structured structured objects were easy
to capture like frogs and sort of you
know objects that were camouflage just
turned into this mush and but on super
resolution now super resolution is
interesting because there's a lot of
conditioning information right and when
you have a lot of conditioning
information the sort of possible you
break you you actually lock a quite a
few of the modes so there's only a few
options you can have at the output and
super hour super resolution results were
much better we were able to get a better
facial orientation and structure than
previous work and these are samples at
different temperatures and and and we
when we quantified this with actual
human evaluators we like we flashed an
image and said is this real is is false
and we were able to we were able to fool
humans like four times better than
previous results on super resolution
again these are not these results are
like I guess the latest guy and result
from Nvidia makes us look like a joke
but I mean this is I mean you're
starting later than Ganso hopefully
we'll catch up but but the point here is
that this is an interesting inductive
bias for images of a natural inductive
bias
for images and and and there's hope to
apply it for a playing and
classification and other search tasks
also so one interesting thing just to
sort of both out of curiosity and asking
how good is maximum I like does maximum
likelihood well one does the model
actually capture some interesting
structure in the role second do you get
diversity what maximum likelihood should
get diversity but by virtue by were true
what it does so then we just redid image
completion and why is why image
completion because as soon as you lock
down half the image to the gold truth
you're actually shaving off a lot of the
possible modes so you have a much easier
time sampling so so the first is first
is what we supplied to the model that
the the right row there the rightmost
colonists is gold and we were able to
generate different samples what was
really interesting is a third row so the
rightmost column is the rightmost column
is gold now if you look at the third row
this horse so actually there's this sort
of glimpse or a suggestion of a poll but
the model hallucinate idatu Minh in some
of these in some of these images which
is interesting like in it does capture
at least the data teaches it to capture
some structure about the world the dog
is just cute and I guess this also shows
that you know there's this entire object
this chair that the model just
completely refuse to imagine so there's
a lot of difficulty and I guess Anna's
going to talk about the another way to
exploit self self similarity thank you
[Applause]
so Thank You ash for the introduction I
so there's a lot of self-similarity and
images there's also a lot of
self-similarity in music so we can
imagine transformer being a good motto
for it we are going to show how we can
add more to to the self attention to
think more about kind of relational
information and how that could help
music generation so first I want to
clarify what is the raw representation
that we're working with right now so
analogous to language you can think
about there's text and somebody is
reading out a text so they add their
kind of own intonation to it and then
you have sound waves coming out that's
speech so if your music there's a really
very similar kind of a line of
generation where you say the composer
has an idea writes down the score and
then performant performs it and then you
get sound so what we're gonna focus on
today is mostly you can think of the
score but it's actually a performance in
that it's a symbolic representation
where MIDI pianos were used and I'm a
professional amateur musicians we're
performing on the pianos so we have the
recorded information over there playing
so in particular at each time step
modeling music as this sequential
process what is being output are okay
turn this note on advance the clock like
this much and then turn to snore off and
also there's dynamics information so
when you turn to know long you first say
like how loud it's going to be so
traditionally modeling music as kind of
a language we've been using recurrent
neural networks and because as it's
usually introduced and and talked about
there's a lot of compression that needs
to happen like a long sequence has to be
embedded into like a fixed length vector
and that becomes hard when in music you
have you have repetition coming at a
distance so I'm first going to show you
samples from from the RN ends from a
transformer and then from music
transformer that has the relative
attention and kind of let you hear the
differences and then I'll go into how we
what whether what are the modifications
we needed to do on top of the
transformer model so here this task is
kind of the image completion task so we
give it an initial motif and then we ask
the model to do continuations so this is
the motif that we fed how many people
recognized there awesome okay yeah so
this is a kind of a fragment from a
chopin etude piece and we're gonna ask
the RNN to do a continuation
[Music]
[Applause]
so you can hear like in the beginning it
was trying to repeat it but very fast it
wandered a lot in - it's a other
different ideas so that's one challenge
because it's not able to directly look
back to what happened in the past and
can just look at a kind of a blurry
version and that blurry version becomes
more and more blurry so this is what the
transformer does so so a detail is these
models are trained on half the length
that you're hearing so we're kind of
asking the model to generalize beyond
the lengths that it's trained on and you
can see for the transformer it
deteriorates beyond that that it can
hold the motif pretty consistent
okay you get you get the idea so
initially it was able to do this
repetition really well so it was able to
coffee very well but beyond the length
it was trained on it kind of didn't know
how to cope with like longer context and
what you see the last one is from the
music transformer that thinks about kind
of the relational information and you
can just see visually how it's very
consistent and kind of repeating these
these larger arcs
[Music]
yeah so that was a music transformer and
so in music the the self-similarity that
we talked about so we see the motif here
so so there we primed the model with a
motif and this is actually a sample
unconditioned sample from the model so
nothing there was no priming that the
model kinda had to create its own motif
and then do continuations from there and
here if we kind of look at it and
analyze it a bit you see a lot of
repetition with gaps in between and if
you look at the self attention structure
we actually do see the model looking at
the relevant parts even if if it was not
immediately preceding it so so here what
I colored shaded out is where the motif
occurs and you can see the different
colors is a different attention heads
and they're kind of focusing among those
grayed out sections so I'll play this
sample and we also have a visualization
that kind of shows you as the music is
is being played a what notes it was
attending to as it was predicting that
note and this was generated from scratch
and so the self attention is from from
kind of no two note level or event to
event level so it's it's quite low level
so when you look at it it's it's a
little bit overwhelming it has like
multiple heads and a lot of things
moving but there is kind of these
structural moments where you would kind
of see more of this clean kind of
sections where it's attending to
[Music]
[Applause]
okay so how do we do that so starting
from kind of the regular attention
mechanism we know it's a weighted
average of the past history and the nice
thing is however far it is we have
direct access to it so if we know there
are kind of motifs that occurred in in
the early on in the piece we're still
able to based on the fact that things
are similar to be able to retrieve those
but it also becomes all the past becomes
kind of a bag of words like there is no
structure of which came before or after
so there's the position or sinusoids as
she's talked about that basically in
this indices indexes into sinusoids that
are moving at different speeds and so
close by positions would have a very
similar kind of a cross-section into
those multiple sinusoids in contrast for
convolutions you kind of have this fixed
filter that's moving around that a
capture is the relative distance like
one before - before and these are kind
of in some ways like a rigid structure
that allows you to be kind of bring in
the the distance information very
explicitly you can imagine relative
attention with the multiple heads at
play to be some combination of these so
on one hand you can access the the
history very directly on the other hand
you also know how you really relate to
this history you're capturing for
example like translational invariance
and and we for example we think one of
the reasons why in the beginning prime
example was that you heard that the
music transformer was able to generate
beyond the link that was trained on in a
very coherent way is that it's able to
kind of rely on this translational
invariance to carry the relational
information forward so if we take a
closer look at how how this works is the
regular transformer you have you compare
all the queries and keys so you get kind
of
the square matrix you can think of it as
like a self similarity matrix so it's a
square
what relative attention does is to add
an additional no term that thinks that
thinks about whenever you're comparing
two things how far are you apart and
also based on the content do I do I care
about things that are two steps away or
three steps away or I may be care about
things that are recurring a kind of a
periodical distance and with that
information gathered that influences the
the similarity between positions and in
particular this extra term is based on
the distance so you want to gather them
beddings that's relevant to that the the
creycrey distance is on the on the
logits
so in translation this has shown a lot
of improvement and in for example
English to to German translation but in
translation the sequences are usually
quite short it's only a sentence to
sentence a translation for example maybe
50 words or 100 words but the music
samples that you heard are in the range
of two thousand times subs so it's like
two thousand tokens need to be able to
fit in memory so this was a problem
because the original formulation relied
on building this 3 D tensor that's I
that's very large a memory and and why
this is the case it's because for every
pair you you look up what the what the
rel is so you can compute what the
relative distance is and then you look
up and embedding that corresponds to
that distance so for like this this
length by length like L by L matrix you
need like to collect embeddings for each
of the positions and that's depth D so
that gives us the 3d what we realize is
you can actually just directly multiply
the queries and the embedding distances
and they come out kind of in a different
order because now you have the queries
order by relative distance but you need
the queries ordered by keys which is
kind of an absolute by absolute a
configuration so what we could do is
just do a C
of skewing - to put it into the right
configuration and this is yes just just
a quick contrast to show the difference
in memory requirements so a lot of times
the challenges is in being able to scale
being able to be more memory efficient
so that you can model longer sequences
so with that this is I can play you one
more example if we have time but if we
don't have time we can go ahead okay so
this is this isn't maybe a one about a
1-minute sample and I I hope you like it
Thanks
[Music]
you
thank you for listening thanks Anna
great so just sort of - so relative
attention has been a powerful mechanism
for a very powerful mechanism for music
it's also helped in machine translation
one really interesting consequence of
relative attention in in images is that
like convolutions achieve convolutions
achieve translational equivariance so if
you have let's say you want you have
this this red dot or this feature that
you're computing at this red dot it
doesn't depend on where this image of
the dog isn't the image is in the larger
image just as it doesn't depend on its
absolute location it's going to it's
going to produce the same activation so
you have the convolutions have this nice
translation like we're variants now with
with with relative positions are
relative attention you get exactly the
same effect because you don't have any
once you just remove this notion of
absolute position that you're injecting
into the model
once you've once you remove that then
your attention computation because that
actually includes I mean Nicky and I and
a couple others of you're actually a
Nana we were actually working on images
and seams and it seems to actually show
better results this actually this now
satisfies this the I mean it can achieve
translation equivariance which is a
great property for images so there's a
lot of it seems like this might be an
interesting direction to pursue if you
want to push self attention and images
for self supervised learning I guess on
South supervised learning so the
generative the generative modeling work
that that I talked about before in
itself just having probabilistic models
of images I mean I guess the best model
of an image is that I go to google
search and I pick up an image and I just
give it to you but I guess generative
models of images are useful because if
you want to do something like semies are
cell supervised learning where you just
pre train them
on a lot of on a lot of unlabeled data
and then you transfer it so hopefully
this is going to help and this is going
to be a part of that machinery another
interesting another interesting
structure that Drella t of attention
allows you to model is kind of a graph
so imagine you have this you have this
similarity graph where these red edges
are this notion of companies and the
blue edges this notion of a fruit and an
apple takes these two forms and and you
could just imagine relative attention
just modeling this just being able to
model or being able to yourself being
able to impose these different notions
of similarity between between different
elements so if you have like if you have
graph problems then relative self
attention might be a good fit for you
there's also there's also some quite a
position paper by Battaglia at all from
deep line that talks about drugs of
attention and how it can be used within
graphs so while we're on graphs I just
wanted a it perhaps might be interesting
to connect some excellent work that was
done on on grass called message-passing
neural networks and it's quite funny so
if you look at if you look at the
message passing function what it's
saying is we're actually just passing
messages between pairs of notes so you
can just think of self attention as
imposing a fully connect it's like a
complete bipartite graph and you're
passing messages between you're passing
messages between notes a message passing
message passing neural networks did
exactly that they were passing messages
between nodes as well and how are they
different well the only way that I mean
well mathematically they were only
different and that message passing was
was forcing the messages to be between
pairs of notes but just because of the
softmax function where you get
interaction between all the notes self
attention is like a message passing
mechanism where the interactions are
between all all notes so they're they're
like they're not too far mathematically
and also the message passing paper
introduces an interesting concept called
multiple towers that are similar to
multi-head attention that know i'm
invented and it's like you run k copies
of these message passing neural networks
in parallel so there's a lot of
similarity between existing you know
this connects to work that existed
before with these connections sort of
came in later we have a graph library
kind of connected these both both these
strands message-passing and we put it
out in tensor - tensor so to sort of
summarize the properties that self
attentions been able to help us model as
this constant path length 22 any two
positions and it's been it's been shown
to be quite useful in in in in sequence
modelling this advantage of having
unbounded memory not having to pack
information and finite in in and if sort
of finite model in a fixed amount of
space where and in in our case our
memory essentially grows up the
sequences is is is helps you
computationally it's trivial to paralyze
you can you can crunch a lot of data
it's which is useful if you wanna have
you have large data sets we found that
it can model self similarity it seems to
be a very natural thing very very
natural phenomena if you're dealing with
images or music also relative attention
allows you to sort of gives you this
added dimension of being able to model
expressive timing and music well this
translation like with variants it
extends very naturally to graphs so this
part or everything that I talked so far
was about sort of parallel training so
there's a very active area of research
now using these self attention models
for for Less auto regressive generation
so notice I at generation time notice
that the decoder mask was causal we
couldn't look into the future so when we
when we are generating we're still
generating sequentially left to right on
the target side so and and and why why
is generation hard well because your
outputs are multimodal if you had if you
want to translate English to German
there's multiple ways and and and your
your second word that you're translating
will depend on the first word for
example if you if you first the first
word that you predict was danke then
that's going to change the second word
that you predict and if you just
predicted them independently then you
can imagine you can just have all sorts
of permutations of these which will be
incorrect and the way we actually break
modes is or we make decisions as just
sequential generation once we commit to
word that that makes a decision and then
that nails down what's the next word
that you're going to predict so there's
been some there's been some work on as
an active research area and you can kind
of categorize some of these papers like
the non auto regressive transformer of
the fast the third paper fast decoding
the fourth paper towards a bed
our understanding of vector quantizer
auto-encoders into this group where
they're actually doing the decision
making in a latent space that's being
it's either being learned using word
alignments fertility Zoar that's being
learned using autoencoders so you make
do you do the decision making in latent
space and then you once you've made the
decisions in latent space you assume
that all your outputs are actually
conditionally independent given that
you've made these decisions so that's
how they actually speed up there's also
there's another paper the second one is
paper that does it early refinement
there's also a block-wise parallel
decoding paper by Mitchell Stern no I'm
she's here and and yacouba's quiet
where they essentially just run multiple
models like and rescore using a more
they decode using a faster model and
score using the more expensive model so
that's how it sort of it speeds it up
transfer learning has had a self
attention has been beneficial transfer
learning GPT from open AI and burt are
two classic examples there's been some
work on actually scaling this up like a
de factor as a efficient optimizer this
is a recent paper by Rohan Anil and your
um singer
there's also mesh tends to flow which
actually they've been able to train
models
there's several orders of magnitude
larger than the original models that be
trained so there's I mean when you're
working this large data regime it
probably going to memorize a lot of you
want to memorize a lot of things inside
your parameters you just train a larger
model message and stuff looking at I can
let you do that there's been other
interesting work Universal transformers
sort of recurrent neural networks can
actually count very nicely let's give
you this cute papers by a she made her
Burberry actually show that recurring
the count the cell mechanism just learns
a nice counter like if you're you can
learn kind of a to the NB to the end
with lsdm so then Universal transformers
brings back recurrence in depth inside
the transformer there's a really cool
thick upto paper
simultaneously with the image
transformer paper that also uses local
attention transformer Excellus paper
that sort of combines recurrence with
self attention so they do self attention
in chunks but they sort of summarize
history by using recurrence it's kind of
cute it's been used in speech but I
don't know if there's been some really
big success stories of self attention
and speech again similar issues we
very large positions to to do self
attention over Sayyaf self supervision
is is a if it works it would be it would
be it would be very beneficial we
wouldn't need large label datasets
understanding transfer transfers
becoming very sick of being a reality in
NLP with Burton some of these other
models so understanding how these what's
actually happening is an interesting
area of ongoing research for me and a
couple and of few my collaborators and
multitask learning and surmounting this
this quadratic problem with self
attention is an interesting area of
research that I that I'd like to pursue
thank you
[Applause]